la loi est entrée en vigueur en janvier
dernier mais sept mois plus tard une
majorité d'armes à feu n'ont toujours
pas été immatriculées en date du 15 ou
698 1260 trois armes avaient été
inscrites au registre sur un total
d'environ 1 million 600 mille
je veux répéter ses punchs à son
chasseur on est encore en mode
sensibilisation information
communication pour inciter les
propriétaires d'armes à respecter la loi
la ministre propose des assouplissements
il ne sera plus nécessaire par exemple
de préciser la longueur du canon au
moment de l'immatriculation le ministère
peine pourtant déjà à traiter toutes les
demandes reçues
cent cinquante mille d'entre elles sont
toujours en attente je suis très inquiet
sur la rage de 150 ne demande pas ce que
tant que sosa existe ça génère un flou
ça génère une incertitude
ça donne une pogne aux opposants
registre pour continuer à faire du
millage moi je pense que la machine est
pauvre tu as fait trop deux le temps de
la roue dream après sur le corner
prendre les décisions qu'ils veulent
la ministre reconnaît sa responsabilité
édito sa soeur de ne pas s'inquiéter ont
fait certains meilleurs culpa nous par
rapport à ça tous ceux qui au moment où
on se parle aujourd'hui on fait des
démarches d'immatriculation dormir
l'esprit tranquille devant les
parlementaires police se souvient a
plaidé pour une application beaucoup
plus musclée de la loi elle s'étonne
qu'aucun constats d'infraction n'est
encore été émis le parti libéral aussi
on trouve que dans un contexte de boé
coque délibéré pour loi de sécurité
publique on peut pas utiliser au lieu de
juste la carotte le bâton
j'ai plutôt d'avis que quand on
contrevient à la loi contrevient à la
loi puis un moment donné il faut qu'il
faut que les chansons sa clique
les chasseurs maintiennent leur
opposition au registre et pensent que
l'argent qui lui est consacrée seraient
mieux investis en santé mentale au rang
des surprises à délivrer coup son calcul
tout pour nous autres c'est aussi une
aberration si vous avez de l'argent même
été là des endroits tels que les
campagnes que nous faisons le chasseur
immatriculent sa remorque bateau il
matricule son drone ci va faire du
repérage sur son territoire mais pour
les armes à feu c'est différent ce soit
vous êtes octroyé plus de ressources au
ministère pour qu'il traite plus
rapidement les demandes en attente
serait politiquement
délicat le registre fédéral est devenu
impopulaire précisément en raison de son
coût et le gouvernement du québec avait
promis de mettre en place le sien à
l'intérieur de budget strictement balisé
ici hugo lavallée radio canada québec